in den letzten jahrzehnten hatte die cdu
die meiste macht und das ergebnis davon
ist dass sich viele sachen für die
reichen finanziell ziemlich geil
entwickelt haben und für alle analyse
der einzige knaller des ganzen
europawahlkampfs youtuber rieso hat den
volksparteien vor allem der cdu ein
ungerechte einkommensverteilung zu wenig
für bildung stillstand beim klimaschutz
sich selbst ziele setzen und nicht
einhalten was das sind für inkompetent
über sieben millionen klicks versetzen
die groko vor der wahl in schockstarre
die cdu will mit ihrer interpretation
von jugend antworten doch das video von
philippe am tor wird wieder einkassiert
vielleicht auch besser so
der lauwarme clip mit
spd-generalsekretär klingbeil erweist
sich als rohrkrepierer erst mal sagen
dass ich es richtig finde das hier
politisch aktiv seid dass ihr freitags
auf die straße geht das hier auf youtube
eure stimme erhebt das ist etwas was bei
uns ankommt
dabei waren cdu und spd vorgewarnt auch
auf die eu urheberrechtsreform gab es
heftige kritik
resource fazit wählt bitte nicht die spd
wählt bitte nicht die cdu wählt bitte
nicht die csu und schon gar nicht die
afd
die anerkennt ist bei uns
unternehmerinnen autoren und seit 2008
in der cdu frau tina wie kann ein
youtube-video so einen schaden anrichten
13 millionen klicks wie geht das das
kann ich wahrscheinlich nicht ganz im
detail erklären was ich interessant
finde ist dass die junge generation eben
auch im vorpolitischen raum bei den
parteien gar nicht stattfindet das
durchschnitts mitglied der partei in der
großen parteien ist 60 jahre alt wir
haben als volkspartei dahingehend
versagt dass wir nicht in die alltags
gehörte unter 30 hinein binden wir
schaffen es in den jugendorganisationen
immer noch in den klassischen
vorpolitischen räumen bei der
freiwilligen feuerwehr beim technischen
hilfswerk die jugendlichen zu erreichen
viele andere aber nicht und deswegen war
es eine frage der zeit bis sich
enttarnte dass die jugend insgesamt sich
von den parteien nicht abgeholt finden
warum haben sie dieses gegen video nicht
produziert für die cdu also ganz formal
gesprochen weil ich nicht gefragt wurde
ich habe schriftlich irgendwann ein paar
tage später mich darauf bezogen und mich
ein bisschen ein bisschen vielleicht
auch gerechtfertigt viel verstanden und
lernwillen glaube ich auch gezeigt fand
auch dass das wahlergebnis eben den den
liberalen den jungen leuten in der cdu
jetzt auch rückendeckung und rückenwind
gibt was bund und wichtig ist aber die
sind nicht gefragt selbst steht mir
glaube ich auch gar nicht so das bin ich
nicht geübt und ich wurde nicht gefragt
rechts neben ihnen sitzt lives 3
millionen follower oder abonnenten eben
netz leute hand aufs herz sie haben
diese unterstützt wie viele andere
youtuber wenn man sich mal anguckt was
er in diesen 55 minuten präsentiert hat
könnte man sagen jemand der regelmäßig
nachrichten liest gerne auch online
der kann einen großteil davon gewusst
haben
glauben sie dass 55 minuten
frontalunterrichts mit lehrer rieso
reichen für eine wahlentscheidung
ich glaube nicht dass es um
frontalunterricht geht ich glaube nicht
dass es um rieso geht ich glaube wir
haben hier ein grundsätzliches konsens
problem das wir gerade auch gelesen habe
gerade gehört haben maniche natürlich
entschuldigung weil auch sie du genau
wie sie oben waren wir beim du
hier sitzen und du sprichst von der
jugend und von den jungen leuten was
hindert dich daran zu sagen wir so warum
bist du mich teil dessen teil der leute
die deine partei kritisieren dass wird
das werde ich in erster linie nicht
verstehen und dann ist es auch nicht
eine sache wo ich sage das ist
frontalunterricht von lehrer rieso nein
das ist jemand der sich heraus genommen
hat seine meinung und seine bedenken und
all das was ihn über viele jahre
frustriert und wahrscheinlich auch
wirklich geärgert hat zusammengetragen
zusammenzutragen zu belegen und in 55
minuten kompakt wie es auch jede andere
show macht ich habe dieses ganze theater
von jemandem wie beispielsweise einem
claus von wagner eine max gut auf die
seit jahren um eine absetzung der
kanzlerin merkel ringen ja in jeglicher
satirischer form noch nie erlebt bis es
plötzlich und dass es öffentlich
rechtliches fernsehen eben bis es
plötzlich jemand im internet gewagt hat
zu sagen aber die nicht mehr so und das
ist eine sache wie werde ich in dieser
ganzen diskussion in dieser ganzen
diskussion entstehen der wichtigsten
artikel unseres grundgesetzes infrage
stellt nicht verstehen und nicht
effektiv und damit kommen wir zur
geografisch linken seite an den tisch
bei uns ist johanna kandl 31 jahre jung
mitglied im präsidium in bayern
stellvertretende parteivorsitzende
volkmann die spd braucht so ein
zerstörer video nicht die zerstört sich
gerade selbst wir geben tatsächlich
gerade keine besonders gute figur ab und
ich muss sagen als ich das video zum
ersten mal gesehen habe ich habe
irgendwie ja weil sie mir ich hab so
empfunden dass er halt einfach einen
nerv getroffen hat das ist das was ich
halt auch irgendwie ständig höher dass
das ja einfach keinen bock mehr auf
diese politik des kleinsten gemeinsamen
nenners mw da ist diese trippelschritte
die vorangegangen werden ohne irgendwie
die großen entscheidenden fragen
anzugehen und das viele auch keine
ahnung mit denen ich spreche die haben
halt einfach das gefühl dass ihre themen
auch nicht nicht besprochen dann auch
nicht in den parteien nicht stattfinden
auch hinten runter fallen und deshalb
glaube ich auch dass es so ein
etappe weil er halt ja da dieses das
gefühl einfach von ganz vielen leuten
auch einfach getroffen hat ist andrea
nahles noch die richtige
parteivorsitzende
ich habe mir schon gedacht dass sie mir
diese frage heute nicht erspart antwort
eine kurze antwort gibt es darauf nicht
weil ich tatsächlich ich bin super
gemacht von dieser personaldiskussion
und ich kann es auch nicht mehr hören
ich weiß nicht ich war auch bei den
demonstrationen im gefäß verfügt gehabt
das angeguckt oder artikel 13 oder so
ich hab das schilder gesehen wo leute
hochgehalten haben welche forderungen
sie haben was sie irgendwie wollen was
worüber diskutiert wird aber ich habe
keine schilder gesehen auf denen gestand
die volksparteien müssen jetzt ihre
vorsitzenden austauschen und deshalb
habe ich auch kein bock mehr dass wir
irgendwie die ganze zeit diese
diskussion führen sondern ich will
endlich über die themen reden damit
junge leute sich ernst genommen der öl
die partei und minister heutige sich
selbst genau dieser personal charisma
sitzt bei ihnen 21 jahre jung kommt aus
münster organisiert in münster
dienstfrei dance for future demus jeder
kann sich im netz äußern friends man das
ist gut und richtig so
wovon hängt es eigentlich ab ob jemand
gehört wird ob er wichtig ist ich glaube
das hängt von ganz ganz vielen
verschiedenen faktoren ab und zum
beispiel bei diesem video video war es
einfach dass es was auf den punkt
gebracht hat das war nicht eben 55
minuten von frontalunterricht und die
leute lernen da was und nehmen das dann
irgendwie mit sondern es war von ganz
ganz vielen das was die leute eh schon
irgendwo im kopf hatten vielleicht nicht
so in dem video gebracht hätten aber das
war schon da das war eine grundstimmung
die also timing genau timing die
artikulation weise die cdu als genau
falsch gemacht sie wollte darauf
antworten verfassten 11 seitiges pdf mit
dem sie vielleicht ja ihre mitglieder
die im durchschnitt 60 jahre alt sind
erreicht aber eben nicht die leute die
das video gesehen habe und ich glaube da
zeigt sich einfach ein
kommunikationsproblem was wir haben
man sieht es in der politik ist werden
nicht die fragen gestellt die leute
gerade bewegen oder zumindest junge
leute und ich glaube das ist das woran
gerade ganz ganz viel scheitert und
warum sich leute so unverstanden fühlen
sich auch nicht in parteien engagieren
sondern vielleicht in anderen formen und
sagen wir bringen uns ein wir gehen auf
die strasse weil wir haben das gefühl es
bringt gar nichts an parteien zugehen
weil da eben nicht die fragen gestellt
werden und die themen diskutiert werden
die man diskutiert werden müssten so und
dann kommen wir zu diesem
auftritt von annegret kramp-karrenbauer
der vorsitzenden der cdu erst hat man ja
wahlbeeinflussung durch russen bots
befürchtet und fake news befürchtet und
jetzt befürchtet die parteivorsitzende
der cdu offensichtlich eine
beeinflussung zugunsten der grünen und
das sagte sie was wir eigentlich in
diesem land los wenn eine reihe von 70
zeitungsredaktionen zwei tage vor der
wahl erklärt hatten wir machen einen
gemeinsamen aufruf welt bitte nicht cdu
und spd das wäre klare meinungsmache vor
der wahl gewesen und die frage stellt
sich schon mit blick auf das thema
meinungsmacher was sind eigentlich
regeln aus dem analogen bereich und
welche regeln gelten eigentlich für den
digitalen bereich ja oder nein
hawking hat jetzt ist meinungsmachern
harter begriff wo geht die grenze
zwischen meinung werbung und
manipulation in kenner
das ist eine frage die kann ich jetzt
glaube ich in der sekunde auch gar nicht
beantworten das ist eine
gesamtgesellschaftliche frage der wir
uns natürlich auch im digitalen raum
stellen müssen
mich stört natürlich dass in einer
wahlanalyse bei der die partei darstellt
als ob sie sehr erfolgreich gewesen wäre
weil sie sich zwei sehr niedrig
gesteckte ziele erreicht hat dass da
nicht die erste botschaft ist wir wo wir
haben eine wahlschlappe auf irgendeine
art und weise erlitten
wir konnten als volkspartei nicht in der
junge generation hinein binden und wir
haben nicht nur ein image und
kommunikationsproblem sondern unsere
politik konzepte wurden einfach nicht
angenommen und deswegen müssen wir uns
in der inhaltlichen erneuerung oder
einer inhaltlichen anderen priorisierung
stellen und das davon abgelenkt wird
indem man negativkampagnen irgendwie
nach vorne stellt und sich ebenso aus
flüchtet in einer nervosität ich von ihr
nicht gewöhnt bin
das erschreckt mich und das ist sehr
unglücklich gelaufen ist annegret kramp
karrenbauer die richtige vorsitzende der
cdu ich habe als es bei uns diesen sehr
lebendigen wettstreiter gab den ich sehr
gut fand zwischen jens spahn friedrich
merz und annegret kramp karrenbauer mich
nicht festgelegt ich fand an annegret
kramp karrenbauer sehr gut dass sie im
dadurch dass sie auch generalsekretärin
war so ein sehr moderierenden stil in
die partei hinein hat wie den ich
wichtig finde auch demokratisch
gesprochen
ich glaube und satz volkspartei macht
eben nicht aus dass wir alle sechs
monate die parteivorsitzende austauschen
insofern wünsche ich mir dass sie aus
ihren fehlern lernt the fleuth drei
millionen menschen folgen ihnen im netz
habe ich schon gesagt
die frau kann karrenbauer möchte sie
regulieren sie sagen nee das mach ich
selbst und das kann ich selbst wie geht
man im netz verantwortlich mit
hunderttausenden abonnenten um
ich denke man geht insofern
verantwortlich damit um wie man es und
hier ist der vergleich zwischen der
analogen welt und der digitalen welt
wahrscheinlich relativ simpel gezogen
es gälten dieselben regeln eins zu eins
wenn sich 70 zeitungsredaktionen dazu
entschieden hätten gegen eine politik
die ihrer meinung ihrer fasson ihrer
auffassung von fairness und von einer
regierung mit der sie wirklich gut leben
können nicht entspricht dann hätten sich
70 zeitungsverleger wer auch immer diese
leistung durchaus möglich und jetzt hat
das in aller regel eben genau dasselbe
zu tun denn wenn nicht sich in eine wahl
einmischen während einer wahlperiode
wann dann
das macht überhaupt keinen sinn um es
deswegen entwicklung sage ich ganz klar
das ist keine das ist keine
meinungsmache es ist eine meinung die
herausgetragen wird und auch jetzt zu
behaupten von wegen es hätten über 10
millionen leute sich irgendwie
manipulieren lassen das ist schon mal da
sieht man dass das grundsätzliche
verständnis für die technik hinter
youtube einfach nicht gegeben ist wenn
zehn millionen klicks heißt nicht zehn
millionen leute haben dieses video
gesehen das ist eine völlig andere
geschichte die erwarte ich schon gar
nicht mehr von leuten die darüber reden
ja aber es ist tatsächlich so dass ich
sage es gälten dieselben regeln
es wird hier überhaupt gar nichts
reguliert und zwar niemals denn dann
sind wir auf einem weg der mir überhaupt
nicht gefällt
und genau so sehen sie und es ist eine
ernste
sie denn eine getan und es unterstellt
man ja sehen sie denn eine gefahr dass
echte youtube stars eben politisch
werbung machen können oder sich für
politische werbung engagieren können und
bezahlen lassen können ohne dass der
absender und der produzent deutlich
werden ich sehe in sofern keine gefahr
dafür dass das in intransparenz ausarte
denn aktuell und in den letzten jahren
wird die transparenz was beispielsweise
werbe einsätze was bezahlte werbung auf
youtube was gekaufte meinung in
anführungsstrichen ganz ganz ganz große
anführungsstriche auf youtube angeht
wird so eng geschnürt dieses konzept
dafür ist so eng dass es nicht möglich
wäre im legalen sinne in deutschland
werbung für jemanden zu machen ohne dass
ganz klar zu career center deutlich wird
und damit sind wir frau kann man
natürlich auch bei der frage was wird
wieso vorgeworfen ihm wird vorgeworfen
zu vereinfachen
ihm wird vorgeworfen mit emotionen zu
arbeiten mit symbolen zu arbeiten
passiert das nicht in jedem wahlkampf
jeder partei ja und deshalb ist es halt
auch totaler quatsch
also auch was was annegret kramp
karrenbauer gesagt hat ist inhaltlich
quatsch ich muss es so deutlich sagen
aber was mich am allermeisten an dieser
ganzen debatte stört ist dass so getan
wird als könnten junge leute nicht
selber denken und könnten sich nicht
selber eine meinung bilden und
vielleicht auch mal darüber reflektieren
was irgendwie oder irgendwie andere
youtuber irgendwie erzählen so also die
schalten ja nicht ihr gehirn aus noch
weise das video geguckt haben sondern
die denken ja selber dann darüber nach
so und deshalb also dass das ärgert mich
wirklich nur dann unterstellt wird die
gucken so ein video und danach machen
sie ihr kreuz das ist doch quatsch und
das ist ja sogar das gegenteil
also ist sogar das gegenteil ich glaube
dass glaube dass die ware effekt ja
sogar im gegenteil liegt dass es endlich
mal so ist dass die dass schulkinder am
essen fisch mit ihren eltern über
politik diskutieren und dass da eine
debatte entfacht wird wo junge leute
endlich mal ein symbol haben dass sie
vielleicht auch ihren eltern zeigen
können dass sie sehr kompakt auf den
punkt bringt was sie vielleicht selber
gar nicht richtig artikulieren können
und das auch ihre eltern vielleicht auch
merken welche politik ihre kinder
irgendwie besser finden und da eben auch
eine inhaltliche erneuerung stattfinden
wenn man/frau reemtsma von einer nie
dagewesenen spaltung der generationen
jetzt spricht ist es nur ein
kommunikationsproblem
nein ist es definitiv nicht nur ein
kommunikationsproblem das ist das auch
also weil wir das was wir erlebt haben
mit dem das wird die mündigkeit
abgesprochen dass junge menschen sich
eine meinung bilden zu bilden können
haben wir nicht nur bei myvideo das
hatten wir bei future als uns gesagt
wurde
ihr wollt doch alle nur die schule
schwänzen das hatten wir bei den artikel
13 demonstrationen das sind alles
gekaufte bot das ist ein
kommunikationsproblem dass es auch
einfach abschätzig gegenüber jungen
menschen weil die können sich genauso
eine meinung bilden wie es erwachsene
menschen und politikerinnen und
politiker können was dazukommt ist
einfach ein problem das die parteien es
anscheinend nicht schaffen die themen
die insbesondere junge menschen aber
auch nicht nur junge menschen
beschäftigen aufzugreifen wenn wir uns
angucken das klimathema 50 fast jeder
zweite deutsche sagt das klima eines der
wahlentscheidenden themen war
gleichzeitig haben wir so ein
zusammengeschusterte klima kabinett was
nicht so richtig was schaffhauser über
ein bisschen gebäudedämmung zu reden ist
nicht schafft große systematische fragen
zu stellen mal zu sagen
wie können wir eigentlich auf einem
planeten der planetare grenzen hat der
uns wirklich eins also probieren co2
budget haben innerhalb dessen die uns
bewegen müssen
wie können wir darauf uns einstellen als
gesellschaft wie können wir vielleicht
auch meine wirtschafts doktrin in frage
stellen diese ewige wachstums extremen
die man nicht zu hinterfragen ist das
noch nötig ist das noch zeitgemäß ist
das vereinbar machen wir gleich sie
sagen es geht nicht nur um kommunikation
sondern tatsächlich um inhalte und um
sehr grundsätzliche frei